halsy and Avril Lavigne joined forces to
perform Avril's hit song girlfriend over
the weekend at palsies annual Halloween
party in Ella the duet seemed like a hit
when the crowd with the crowd and best
part Halsey was dressed as the Marilyn
Manson and Levine was wearing a Madonna
costume
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
kind of wish I was there to see that
live that was awesome yeah that's
happened again no working with Madonna
cross him I love it I love it when I saw
how they didn't even recognize her
yeah I was trying to even like instantly
I was like oh yeah that Marilyn Manson
music video that he was in that of
course so big she looked amazing I just
love that when it comes to Halloween
weekend with all the celebs seeing who's
dressed as what but I think those two
together and singing that song it's
great yeah you see them together unite
but Halloween this year it seems like a
lot of people what are you wearing for
Halloween is there anything particular
already done the Sanderson sisters I was
Winifred Sanderson and ice what else did
I do oh I was a cat but like cat woman
like okay um and then recently it was a
witch with my sisters we go all of it to
sister was we go all out we just like to
do these trio costumes together but yeah
I'm still trying to figure out what I'm
gonna be wearing but my one daughter is
an astronaut and the other one is a cow
but it's two part cow so she's the cow
in the back and then her friends in the
front so I'm not sure how that's gonna
work on Halloween but oh my geez account
we met together yeah they wanted some
dancing cow so they're dressing up the
cow as well so oh I love that oh be
interesting do you get into Halloween
anyway I do but the weather's not that
great this year so I'm nervous about
that but I love Halloween I hope
everyone does too